That’s me. Sana. Making chai for a bunch of people.
And those, are the bunch of people.
For as long as I can remember, chai has been an inseparable part of my life.
I was born in Pakistan but was a super cute baby when my family left the country for the United States.
And while we held onto a lot of cultural traditions,
it’s been chai that probably became the strongest link between my everyday here and my roots.
And I think that’s because chai is such a mundane part of life in South Asia - unlike wedding celebrations -
that having something so everyday from your roots, that’s a routine, makes the connection to your heritage
..a little more real.
Even though I low-key admit that I’ve never been a huge chai drinker on my own.
Hey guys, I’m sana and welcome to my chai night where I’m gonna talk to some friends about their love of chai
and how while it is something that connects us to our roots,
it has a really complicated history and kinda makes for a complicated relationship.
Hint: colonialism.
So, every so often I hold chai nights at my place.
And I’m holding one tonight with a bunch of friends who I just wanted to talk about what tea means to them
and why they drink it and also about their own habits.
Tea for me means having guests over.
Chai reminds me of my mom.
Chai is culture.
Tea means comfort.
I don’t want to say it’s a replacement for bars or things like that but it serves a similar function
where it’s just something to do.
Typically in Algerian culture, we actually drink a lot of coffee.
So tea was always like a sense of comfort and also for guests.
One of the things in the immigrant experience, at least for my parents, was that they were able to hold on to their identity.
And I really believe that with every cup of chai that we’ve had in our house we retain that culture.
And before you go “but Sana, how is tea relevant to my life???” or you go
“yes Sana, spill the literal tea!!” - here’s a  super quick rundown of how big tea is in the United States.
While Americans love coffee - thanks Boston tea party for stigmatizing tea - Americans actually drink a LOT of tea.
According to the Tea Association of the USA, 80% of American households have tea.
And almost 160 million Americans are drinking tea, in some form (mostly black), on any given day.
And the United States, by the way, is the third largest importer of tea in the world.
Meaning, it's not some fringe culture - it's part of the mainstream.
But what does tea mean to those of us who are immigrants or are in the diaspora?
Is it just a hot drink or something more?
Chai is hospitality. Chai is taking care of people. That’s what it’s always been in our family.
It’s having people come over, everybody always wants chai and that’s kind of how it started for us
and that’s kind of how it’s become for me as well.
When people think about tea they always associate
it with chai and I’m from Indonesia and usually tea doesn’t come with milk. We use a lot of jasmine tea.
My mom also taught me how to make chai.
And when I look back now, it means a lot to me just because I never knew my grandparents,
I never knew my aunts when I was younger or my uncles. And just thinking about the fact
that, you know, there’s some family tie there in the way they’ve learned the recipe, it kind of makes me feel like I’m connected to my family in that way.
It’s the national drink of Egypt. I know lots of relatives of mine don't actually drink water.
So, when I ask them what they drink when they're thirsty, they say ‘we drink tea’.
The way I consume tea, I mean, my parents would be so upset to see.
I'm just using teabags; I don’t have the tea set up with the samovar with the piece on top
where you have the strong tea brewing.
Obviously a connection with my mother; she’s a serial chai drinker.
She needs to have her three cups a day. If she doesn’t have one cup, then the world is ending.
I actually don’t really drink that much chai, but I always make chai for everyone.
And for me, personally, when I smell chai, when I see it, when I make it - I'm reminded of my parents and
their inability to function in the morning, late morning, early afternoon, late afternoon or night, without it.
And it’s this incredibly ordinary ritual that I can either keep super low-key by microwaving a bag of Lipton
in a cup and adding some milk or going all out and boiling a big cauldron of chai with cardamom and cinnamon.
But tea isn’t without a history that could complicate the way that a lot of us, especially from South Asia, relate tea or chai to our roots.
Now while it originates from China, tea is, kinda, the result of empires clashing.
For a lot of societies in the world, tea is the result of colonialism.
And for that, I’m gonna throw it to Graham Cornwell, a PhD candidate at Georgetown, who talks a bit about tea and politics.
Tea is the product of colonialism and empire, but not just the British Empire.
It's actually sort of the product of imperial rivalries.
Dutch, British, Portuguese rivalries over access to tea.
For South Asians like me, our tea habits are actually rooted in the British colonial experience.
The British had developed a habit for tea - especially very sweet tea - in the mid-19th century but they couldn’t break China’s monopoly on tea cultivation.
Until they did, by taking tea to India and using what they referred to as the 'jewel in the crown of the British Empire' to cultivate tea.
They do this primarily for economic reasons, the taste, sort of the appetite, the thirst, I guess
for tea in Britain is such that they need to find ways to cultivate it more cheaply and in larger quantities.
But even then tea, or chai as some of us call it in South Asia, didn’t really become popular until much later.
In fact, for the longest time, chai was the drink of the elite.
And in India, that meant those with close connections to the British Empire itself.
And it’s only after the partition of India and Pakistan, so mid-20th century, that chai becomes something
that even the everyday man or woman can drink.
And that’s because of how British-led  tea production in the Empire, especially South Asia, evolved.
You have developments in transportation and the opening of the Suez Canal.
Things that sort of make commerce easier for many parts of the world.
And then, of course, the British tea plantations in India expand tea production in the world.
And so there's  simply more to go around and this drives the price down over time.
As it becomes cheaper, more people try it.
So, how do my friends here feel, knowing that one of their most cherished daily rituals is actually
the byproduct of empire and colonialism?
I don’t think it’s taken away anything from what chai means to me, in itself, though.
Chai always has been chai to us. It’s never been chai tea, it’s never been chai latte, it’s just been chai. Right?
Being an Algerian I’ve always seen, like the way that we make tea is with mint, and I’ve always seen it as being a Maghreb thing.
Maghreb meaning Algeria, Morocco, Tunisia, Libya.
I think so much of what we consume are these kind of hybrid products of this post-colonial world we live in.
So, what would Italian food be without tomatoes which are a new world fruit.
What would thinking about chai with milk or Bánh mì - all of these things that are now every day practices for people.
I think you get into kind of tricky territory when you want to seperate out
what’s authentic and what’s a kind of colonial construction.
All history is complicated.
But at least the complicated and sometimes uncomfortable history behind this cup of chai,
gave us something to come together over.